oh hey hey what's up huh
wait
why are we best friends because our
boyfriends have tattoos for next oh
right
i love him
i love you too
machine gun kelly has some thoughts
about pete davidson's impression of him
it's hard to top that one man on
saturday night live the comedian poked
fun at the rocker and his relationship
with megan fox during the people's court
sketch with host kim kardashian who
pretended to be her older sister
kourtney kardashian posing as a judge
order order order in the courtney
i'm good at this during the sketch court
calls in her bailiffs and besties
machine gun kelly played by pete and
megan played by chloe feynman and
clearly the couple could not keep their
hands off each other i wrote you an
instagram caption babe oh that was fire
all right
achingly beautiful boy oh
toxic oh viral oh twin flame rehab
barbie oh i wish i could vape you
hey yo hey yo keep in mind this is
coming from kanye but y'all weird so
what was mgk's response to pete's
impression well the musician wrote on
twitter quote i think it's time for me
to come on the show as pete mgk also
shared the clip on his instagram story
writing pete you know damn well i don't
talk like that and he also added a
screenshot facetiming pete with the
caption twins
i love him
i love you too the imitation was spot on
pete and chloe even dressed in the same
outfits that the real-life couple wore
to the 2021 iheartradio music awards
something they also nailed the couple's
unapologetic pda which e.t saw
at the 2021 vmas how did you coordinate
these outfits this evening
yeah did machine gun take the lead and
then meg and you were like oh he was
like you're gonna be naked tonight and i
was like whatever you say
daddy whatever daddy says are you proud
of him very proud he's the most talented
boy in the world like we said
unapologetic pda can you guys look
awesome we'll be back uh
i don't know if this is family friendly
y'all
while pete and chloe had fun as mgk and
megan kim and mikey day poked fun at
courtney and her bow travis barker
travis baby
i have to do my show
i can't help it your honor oh my god did
you just call me your honor
yeah babe baby baby babe you're so epic
oh you're so punk
but don't worry there's no bad blood
between the sisters court praised kim's
impression on instagram writing ah this
is everything kim you killed snl i think
you have to have a sense of humor as for
kim's estranged husband kanye west well
chris redd did his best impression of
the rapper i said kim hacked me
are you saying hacked
yeah bro like okay does this even sound
like me who seemed to play wicked i've
seen it four times that ain't me fam but
in reality e.t learned that kanye
himself was involved in kim's prep
behind the scenes a source told e.t last
week
kim and kanye are in a great place and
they always bounce ideas off of each
other and look to each other for advice
and guidance and this gig is no
exception
[Music]
you